In addition to using the media
attribute on a linked style sheet,
there are two other ways you
can apply media queries.
You can embed them with an @media tag,
or
you can embed them with an @import tag.
For performance reasons,
you definitely want to avoid @import.
It's pretty expensive and perf matters.
You'll need to weigh the costs
between linked CSS and @media.
With linked CSS,
you've got many small files, but
many HTTP requests,
where as with @media,
you've got fewer requests, but the files
tend to be a little bit bigger.
Any filter that meets the criteria
of the resulting CSS block,
will be applied using the standard
CSS rules of precedence.
That means when the viewport
is less than 500 pixels,
no styles are applied but above 500
pixels my body color becomes orange.
And above 800 pixels,
not only do I have the orange text, but
I also have the blue background.
I'm pretty sure that also means, I've
got some pretty bad taste in colors.